passez formidable j'ai fait un livre
ceux des deux oui à porter c'est vrai et
puis c'est vrai que ça a été vraiment
une bouffée une bouffée d'oxygène ce
livre d'abord parce que j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses sur la religion juive
et elle est là aussi après vos boutures
sur la religion musulmane et puis on est
des femmes je sais pas je trouve qu'on a
un regard différent sur la religion sur
les rapports avec les gens on est on
était des plus sensibles moi que moi je
trouve qu'il ya il ya dans votre livre
quelque chose que les blue hissant c'est
le fait que vous vous arrachez chacune à
vos communautés d'origine après des
trajectoires ou normalement vous devriez
vous détestez vous avez été programmé
pour vous et testé et au fond vous
montrer cette extraordinaire liberté que
vous avez par rapport une tradition qui
vous programmez vous détestez de vous
aimer et ça je pense que c'est un
enseignement une leçon qui mille fois
plus importante que si ça venait de
l'extérieur et qu'on disait aimez vous
les uns les autres au que la république
intervenait pour dire maintenant des il
faut pas que l'arbre éducation déclarant
mes parents m'ont toujours élevés dans
le respect bon mes parents ont vécu avec
et avec les musulmans donc c'est vrai
qu'il disait côte à côte en algérie donc
oui il ya un moment dans votre idéologie
de saab
si votre père qui multi à tort nous avez
vous donné une gifle à maignon les
cabinets comme des arabes
l'arabe c'est ma première langue et
aucune raison de se détester de mon père
parle parle arabe
ma mère - tic - parce qu'elle est parti
très tôt mais c'est vrai que toute ma
famille moi j'ai été élevé avec des
berceuses bercé avec des berceuses arabe
que chante maintenant à mon roman au
cigare temps est venu maintenant mais il
ya encore des millions de personnes qui
vivent la tolérance et le respect c'est
pas un épiphénomène on n'est pas obligé
de pour moi il n'ya même pas de veine
communautaire entre nos communautés ici
pour moi il ya des minorités bien sûr
qu'à des minorités bien sûr il ya des
clichés antisémites et l'actualité
montre que malheureusement on
on n'est pas sortis mais pour moi c'est
une minorité parce que on vit très bien
toutes les deux elles à elle a suivi
toute ma grossesse j'ai accouché d'un
petit garçon elle était prêt noah la wii
en profiter pour dire que donc demain à
15 heures place de la république
il ya une marche pour ilan halimi donc
voilà tout le monde peut y aller
évidemment j'aimerais que tout le monde
y ait des gemmes inquiète tout le monde
ne soit pas une affaire de juifs parce
que la mort de dylan
il était quand même français et moi ce
qui m'a choqué c'est que on a présenté à
faire au début on a dit la communauté
juive va être choqués êtres blessés va
être en deuil il faut qu'elle se calme
etc
mais pour moi c'est une affaire de la
république c'est une affaire de tout le
monde toutes les mamans musulmanes
doivent ressentir ce que ruth halimi a
rempli d'eau non dans leur chair elles
doivent décembre et j'espère qu'à
descendre
moi je trouve ce crime ignoble
c'est vrai que j'ai été très très
choquée dans le var les circonstances
dans lesquelles en tout cas il a un est
décédé
je voudrais juste dire une chose parce
que c'est vrai qu' on est tous plus ou
moins réactif selon nos origines et
selon si nos appartenances religieuses
je voulais juste lancé un appel pour que
finalement les esprits s'apaisent
parce que je crois que c'est très très
important je crois qu'on on est tous
emportés par ce tourbillon médiatique
autour de cette affaire c'est horrible
on veut dire on est tous il faut tous en
tout cas il faut qu'on soit tous
solidaires pour dénoncer ce genre de
crime et que cela ne se reproduise plus
mais c'est très important si que ça ne
soit pas eu une porte ouverte à de à des
amalgames et qu'on ne met pas tout le
monde dans le même panier
voilà parce que je pense que la majorité
des mouvements en france sont choqués
par ce crime
et moi je pousse et je fais un et je
lance un appel justement à tous les
musulmans de france à tous les français
de confession musulmane parce que c'est
très important les français on est
musulman il faut descendre et soutenir
la famille demain en tout cas à partir
de 15 heures maintenant qu'on appelle à
au président chirac
bien d'autres choses moi ce que le même
point de vue aussi c'est vrai que c'est
un problème qui est moi pour moi je
pense que ça regarde tout le monde c'est
pas simplement la communauté juive ou
vrai qu'on est tous concernés c'est moi
c'est un jeune qui a à peu près mon âge
et je m'appelle apparemment c'est une
compatible tout ça je pense que même
même ma mère j'en parlais cet après midi
avec ma mère me disait qu'avec à
participer à ces manifestations quand
c'est un quartier le silence il ya donc
beaucoup de lâcheté et je trouve que les
gens ont peur et parce qu'ils ont peur
ils ne disent pas les choses et je vois
que nous sommes responsables
la société vous avez raison de dire
c'est pas inaperçu juive ou palestiniens
ou arabes
c'était la française mais en même temps
les gens comment on peut savoir qu'un
jeune homme est enfermé pendant trois
semaines dans une cave est que personne
ne sache rien personne là jean marc
marino rien donc il ya une façon de
silencieuse qui est une lâcheté et qu'il
faut dire où je ne peux avoir peur et
que et que ce que disait ma fille tout à
l'heure faut pas non plus dramatiser il
ya beaucoup de gens formidables mais
surtout qu'un appel anonyme on aurait pu
le sauver
ça qui est bien trop d'attentisme aussi
de la part des citoyens il faut peut
être aussi con qu'on travaille là-dessus
il ya une phrase terrible de tristan
bernard qui disaient ils croient qu'ils
sont heureux parce qu'ils sont immobiles
ou jamais être immobile ans chez nous
alors dans votre livre après vos racines
et vos histoires personnelles vous
raconter les mythes les clichés les
fantasmes et les préjugés auxquels vous
avez été confronté alors c'est vrai que
des images comme ça qui rôdent quoi la
râpe musulmans broc c'était le celui qui
venait voler le pain des français voilà
c'était l'image
ces voix-là effectivement et
malheureusement ils ont que les parents
en tout cas les les la génération de
leurs parents puisque il ya quelques
années était des [ __ ] justement au
service de la france au service de
l'économie de la france
et puis les années après leurs enfants
sont devenus des racailles qu'on doit
nettoyer au kärcher donc trouve ça quand
même lamentable repasse quand même d'une
heure d'une image et l'amalgamé qu'on a
souvent dénoncé ici avec jamel debbouze
domitien lendemain du 11-septembre
musulmans intégristes qui est absolument
insupportable
bien sûr c'est un supporter à cri faut
le dire quoi de file le long 11 11
septembre les musulmans n'a pas la cote
quoi il n'a pas la cote et c'est vrai
que c'est terrible quand même que les
musulmans soient devenus aussi dans la
majorité des boucs émissaires à bon
compte quoi et moi je suis la première
choqué parce que je pense que la
majorité des musulmans en france dénonce
ce genre de terrorisme en tout cas on
est tous les musulmans en france sont
contrôlées les terroristes contre les
kamikazes et je vais dire arrêtez la
majorité des musulmans dans la rue ils
vous répondront la même chose on avait
rappelé qu'en dit des journalistes
français ont été enlevés en irak ce sont
les musulmans de france qui se sont
levés pour aller les défendre et pour
aller là-bas discuter avec les autorités
donc on a vu à l'époque souvenez vous
tous les observateurs français était un
peu un peu
laitonnés dynamique comment on pensait
que c'était une communauté fait mais pas
du tout et en fait il était solidaire de
la france d'abord et avant tout de leurs
concitoyens d'abord et avant tout mais
donc on a vu qu'ils se lever en revanche
c'est vrai que pardon de vous le dire
mais avec les affaires des caricatures
de mahomet vous n'y pouvez rien ça donne
une image terrifiante de l'islam et il
faut beaucoup d'intelligence pour ne pas
faire l'amalgamme et donc moi je dis que
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
que ce soit des gens qui émane de la
communauté elle-même ou des communautés
elles mêmes qui disent non arrêtons et
je pense que sur un sujet comme celui
dont on parlait tout à l'heure cette
affaire halimi qu est terrifiante
il faut aussi qu'on entende vraiment la
voix des musulmans qu'on entende
voilà et c'est pour ça que j'y reviens
le fait que votre lit soit écrit à deux
voies comme ça c'est très important on a
vu on a vu les clichés évidemment que
sont ravalés sur les musulmans sur les
juifs c'est pareil on l'a vu encore avec
la sphère de ilan halimi
les juifs sont riches dirige le monde
alors voilà même quarante mille en
france peut-être le dire ça fait quand
même 10 % des communautés juives et il
ya des déshérités
alors olivier à vous évoqué l'agression
dans votre frère a été victime et le
refus du commissariat de considérer que
c'est une agression antisémite à cause
des quotas en fait c'est à dire que
c'est des directives dites-vous qu'ils
ont reçu si des pouvoirs plus l'état
c'est à dire que c'est une banlieue
calme paisible où il ya de bonnes
statistiques dont il ya pas
d'antisémitisme et y en aura pas voilà
donc ça faisait tache mon frère c'est
agressé ça c'était donc la planoise veut
dire que ces voiles à une agression
antisémite qui fait qu'après quand il
publie les terres des statistiques
c'est évidemment les chiffres sont
meilleurs et vous évoquez dieudonné vous
dites la justice ne lui a jamais donné
tort à une époque j'entendais beaucoup
de choses sur dieudonné
donc je me suis dit il faut quand même
que ça allait voir le spectacle parce
que bon j'aime pas les préjugés j'essaye
de pas en avoir et je suis pour la
liberté d'expression donc c'est vrai que
je voulais voir avant de condamner
est ce que j'ai vu ça m'a tellement
c'est vrai que ça m'a beaucoup choqué
est ce que je trouvais que c'était une
telle incitation à la
je me suis senti vraiment très mal et je
me suis dit bon c'est vrai que là les
clichés sont alors là on passe de du
peuple élu au gie sioniste voilà c'est
ça dure deux heures et demi
d'acharnement sur les juifs et à notre
époque je trouve que c'est pas c'est pas
la bonne solution alors alors vous
raconter kenza la discrimination dont
sont victimes les musulmans dans la
recherche d'emplois dans la recherche de
logement et surtout qu'ils sont obligés
de changer de prénom pour trouver du
boulot c'est terrible quand même qu'on
puisse renier ses origines pour pouvoir
trouver un travail quoi
enfin moi je n'ai pas vécu
personnellement mais j'ai vécu par
contre la discrimination pour trouver un
appartement malgré malgré le fait que il
paraît que je suis une
comme on dit j'aime pas ce mot là mais
parce que je suis une arabe lice à moi
j'aime pas cette phrase là ça veut dire
quoi une arabie ça veut dire qu'il ya
des arabes qui sont listées ya des
arabes qui sont frisés et pas et pas
acceptable ça me semble et avec ma mère
le fait de superbes rouge et je suis sûr
des frises s'intégrer aussi prendre des
noms français est plus simple non mais
c'est vrai moi c'est d'accepter le pays
dans lequel on met mon père était rude
mois laissé rentrer à mazda crédit
surtout quand on fait des cadeaux et il
se trouve que je m'appelle françois mon
père j'ai dit voilà on apprenne ont bien
français voilà on est bien français et
puis y'a pas on dit voilà la famille est
une famille et des enfants qui naissent
pourquoi tout à coup garder la longueur
d'année des mois
oui bon d'accord quoi alors pourquoi ne
pas dire qu'elle n'existe pas tout
simplement ya plus de soucis de
musulmans et c'est comme ça qu'il va
bientôt s'appeler corrie est ce que tout
ce qui est bon en france pour moi c'est
je passais la différence marche pouvoir
marcher doaré voir un bleu avec un
beurre et un blanc un juif ces jeux pas
pour moi césar maintenant s'il faut
passer par là s'appelait mûri sous
michel pour pouvoir passer bien quelque
part c'est tout ça triste pour moi ces
derniers mois mais dd mamadou des noms
mais ça non mais quand je disais ça tu
sais qu'il ya amené au programme accepte
aussi la halle le pays dans lequel on
vit et puis d'intégrer ce mois là où
vous rejoignez toutes les deux c'est sur
la condition de la femme
ce qu'on se rend compte en fait en
lisant votre bouquin que finalement les
femmes juives sont pas mieux lotis que
tant que les femmes musulmanes alors les
musulmanes vous dites en tous les cas
que d'après la loi d'après le coran
elles ont le droit de choisir leur mari
de divorcer d'avoir leurs propres
revenus
c'est des choses qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas admis ça plutôt pas très connu
dans tous les cas c'est parce qu'on
préfère
on préfère mettre en avant des versets
du coran qui sont beaucoup plus comme on
veut dire qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
négative pour la femme parce qu'il ya
des choses aussi qui sont très belle
dans la religion musulmane moi il ya
déjà des principes d'humanité qui émane
directement du coran mais bien sûr il
faut aussi repositionné le coran dans
son époque
clairement il ya des versets du coran
qui sont inacceptables aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis des femmes forcément donc sur
la virginité sur les mariages forcés par
exemple
témoin de mariage forcé je suis contre
et je trouve ça je trouve que c'est un
scandale je pense que il faut quand même
pas oublier que les chiffres sont assez
élevés un haut niveau des mariages
forcés en france je ne saurais pas dire
combien mais à peu près et ça ces
approches des cinquante mille cas ici
encore en france des jeunes filles en
plus qui sont nés en france
sauf qu'à un moment donné il ya une
fracture culturelle qui fait que les
parents préfèrent marier leurs filles
blade et les envoyer se marier avec un
homme de la barre oui les pères ou les
frères touré effectivement voilà donc il
ya une fracture culturelle au sein de la
famille qui fait qu'à un moment il ya je
sais pas y ait un retour aux sources
alors concernant les femmes juives on va
pas épiloguer sur les obligations liées
aux monstres ulation j'ai découvert la
beauté là je savais pas du même temps ça
ne concerne qu'une minorité faut bien le
dire 11e croire voilà c'est quand même
heureusement on en n'est pas comme ça on
est pas tous comme ça et voilà cette
fois mais en fait quand on appelle ça
nida quand on a ses règles
on n'a pas le droit de dormir avec son
mari pendant son dort sur un matelas
séparer on reste pendant 7 jours vous
aller tremper dans un dans un bain et
après voilà et après on a droit
voilà la droite au lit conjugal
tout à fait sympa jovial divorce et
c'est un truc que je savais pas du tout
enfin évidemment c'est les gens qui sont
très pratiquants très orthodoxe
j'imagine à prendre vivant ah bon parce
que ça me concerne aussi par exemple
ouais c'est le divorce la femme doit
obtenir l'accord de son mari pour
divorcer et lui n'a pas besoin d'obtenir
l'accord de sa femme pour divorcer c'est
à dire que quand on se marie
quand on se marie si vous voulez moi
quand je me suis marié on signe tout les
deux normalement pour moi l'acte de
mariage
et quand j'allais prendre le crayon pour
signer aux médias non toi tu signes
passé seulement l'homme qui signent et
moi aussi j'ai trouvé ça ça la synagogue
oui bien sûr on peut divorcer civilement
mais pas religieusement
donc après si on se remet et seront se
remarie civilement avec quelqu'un on est
considéré comme adultère donc les
enfants de cette union sont des bâtards
donc c'est quand même il est peut-être
temps que sa chance du travail et
religieux - aussi oui et liv mans
libéral quand même à changer des choses
il donnait une égalité avec l'opéra mais
les 70 en france parce qu'en france on a
quand même la palme du judaïsme vieillot
parce que après israël c'est pas comme
ça ouais donc que c'est quand même un
peu étrange et pas mal merci